Yeah,
let me,
let me give you an example and I don't
really have the numbers memorized,
but you can get the gist.
There is an example of pretty common
example that's used that you have a
sister that's 22 twin sisters and
they're both 25 years old.
One sister at 25 saved $2,000 a year for
10 years until she's 35.
Okay.
And then she stops at 35 and she just
lets that $20,000 grow until she's 65.
Meanwhile her twin sister did not save
that whole 10 years.
She starts when she's 35 years old at
the time when her other sister quit
saving and she saves $2,000 a year for
the next 30 years until she's 65 years
old,
which she saved a total of $60,000.
Do you know who ends up with more money?
Sr One who only saved $20,000 compared
to her sister who saved for 30 years a
total of $60,000 and fact sr one who
again only say for 10 years almost has
double the amount of money of the second
sister who saved more but waited longer.
You know,
waited 10 years before she started
saving.
That is the power of compound growth.